SAME AD BUT TOOK -- COMPLIED
WITH THAT AND TOOK OUT THE LOGO.
JOINING ME NOW IS TIFFANY
SMILEY.
THE MOST GALLING PART OF ALL OF
THIS IS THAT THE SEAHAWKS, I
UNDERSTAND, GAVE YOUR HUSBAND
THAT JERSEY.
IS THAT CORRECT?
>> THAT IS TRUE.
HE WAS THE 12TH MAN FLAG RAZOR
AND, YOU KNOW, A WHOLE STADIUM
FULL OF FANS CHEERED FOR HIM AND
WERE HONORED TO HAVE HIM BE A
PART OF THAT.
IT'S REALLY UNFORTUNATE.
YOU KNOW, LAURA, I DON'T THINK
IT'S ANY COINCIDENCE THAT THE
SEAHAWKS, STARBUCKS, AND SEATTLE
TIMES HAD THIS COORDINATED
ATTACK AGAINST ME, BECAUSE I'M
TALKING ABOUT ISSUES THAT ARE
ACTUALLY AFFECTING WASHINGTON
FAMILIES.
SKY ROCKETING INFLATION.
CRIME THROUGH THE ROOF.
I SPENT LAST WEEK AT A HOMELESS
ENCAMPMENT IN SEATTLE, I CLEANED
UP DIRTY NEEDLES.
I TALKED WITH THE RESIDENTS AND
YOU KNOW WHAT THEY TOLD ME?
THEY SAID EVERYTHING CHANGED.
THESE ARE PEOPLE ADDICTED TO
DRUGS EVERY DAY THAT WE JUST
ALLOW TO LIVE ON THE STREET.
THEY SAID EVERYTHING CHANGED
WHEN FENTANYL CAM ON OUR STREETS
AND THEY ASKED ME WHAT CAN YOU
DO ABOUT IT TIFFANY?
AND I WAS CLEAR.
THERE IS SOMETHING WE CAN DO
ABOUT IT.
YOU KNOW, LAURA, I WOULDN'T EVEN
BE SURPRISED IF PATTY MURRAY
WORKED WITH THESE WOKE
CORPORATIONS TO TRY TO BRING MY
ADS DOWN, BECAUSE THEY TELL THE
TRUTH ABOUT HER FAILED POLICIES.
>> Laura: THEY'RE PETRIFIED.
>> YES, AT SMILEY FOR
WASHINGTON, WE CAN WIN THIS
RACE, WE WILL WIN THIS RACE.
PATTY MURRAY, A 30 YEAR
INCUMBENT, I WAS 11 WHEN SHE WAS
FIRST ELECTED.
SHE IS NOT ADDRESSING ANY OF
THESE ISSUES THAT ARE FACING
WASHINGTON FAMILIES EVERY DAY.
WE ARE AND WE HAVE A VISION.
>> Laura: I WANT TO POINT OUT
THAT THE SEAHAWKS TIMING IS
PRETTY INTERESTING CONSIDERING
THIS PAST SATURDAY DEMOCRAT
WASHINGTON STATE REP CANDIDATE
TARA SIMMONS POSTED THIS ON HER
OFFICIAL CAMPAIGN FACEBOOK PAGE.
YEAH.
TIFFANY, THIS POST LOOKS A LOT
MORE LIKE AN ENDORSEMENT THAN
YOUR HUSBAND WATCHING THE GAME
IN A JERSEY, WOULDN'T YOU SAY
THAT?
>> WELL, LOOK, WE NEED TO ELECT
LEADERS WHO WILL SOLVE THE
ISSUES.
AND JUST STICK TO FOOTBALL.
YOU KNOW, STICK TO FOOTBALL AND
LET THAT ENTERTAIN THE GREAT
PEOPLE OF WASHINGTON STATE.
AND LET'S START ELECTING PEOPLE
WHO ACTUALLY GET WORK DONE.
YOU KNOW, THE HOMELESS
ENCAMPMENT THAT I WAS AT WAS
ACTUALLY VERY, VERY CLOSE TO THE
SEAHAWKS STADIUM.
IT BROKE MY HEART, LAURA, TO SEE
THE PAIN, TO SEE THE HEART
BREAK, TO SEE WHAT WE ALLOW IN
OUR BEAUTIFUL STATE.
THESE PEOPLE NEED HELP.
AND I WILL HELP THEM.
I WILL MAKE SURE ALSO THAT
SENATOR MURRAY, WE STOP HER IN
HER TRACKS BY WINNING THIS
NOVEMBER AND WE STOP THE 87,000,
STADIUM FULL OF IRS AGENTS FROM
COMING AFTER HARD-WORKING
WASHINGTON FAMILIES.
THERE IS SO MUCH AT STEAK IN
THIS ELECTION.
WE ARE WINNING THE MESSAGING
WAR.
WE HAVE A VISION, WE HAVE HOPE,
WE HAVE SOLUTIONS TO THE
PROBLEMS THAT WASHINGTON
FAMILIES ARE AFFECTING.
>> Laura: YOU'RE A THREAT TO
THEM.
TIFFANY YOU'RE A THREAT TO THEM
IN SO MANY WAYS WE CAN'T EVEN
COUNT THEM TONIGHT ON THE SHOW.
SUFFICE IT TO SAY WHEN THE THREE
BIG ONES COME AFTER YOU IN A
5-DAY SPAN YOU'RE DOING
SOMETHING RIGHT.
I'M VERY EXCITED ABOUT THIS I
SAY RA.
I THINK WE HAD YOU ON FIRST ON